bienvenue d'un point de vue bienvenue
dans ce nouveau débat 50 minutes de
débat sur l'actualité l'actualité qui
nous vient aujourd'hui 2 séoul depuis la
corée du sud
françois hollande s'en prend vertement à
emmanuel macron l'interdiction de parler
de politique française à l'étranger
c'était sans doute le vieux monde
le monde de la pauvreté celui-là il ne
disparaît pas il peut être jeune il
serait 3 millions d'enfants en france à
vivre sous le seuil de pauvreté
c'est aujourd'hui la journée du refus de
la misère de la bonne conscience à peu
de frais on va en parler
le scandale weinstein continue aux
etats-unis ou par ricochet il atteint
donald trump et en france où le hashtag
balances ton port sert d'exutoire à des
milliers de femmes qui se décrit
victimes de harcèlement sexuel
enfin une autre polémique bien franco
française celle là où va l'argent des
radars
et bien pas forcément là où on le croit
vous allez le découvrir vous vous
rendrez bercoff ci d'être avec nous vous
êtes écrivain journaliste vous animez
notamment une émission quotidienne sur
sud radio et vous êtes l'auteur de
donald trump les raisons de la colère
c'est paru chez first en 2016 bonjour
jean marc rozé bon directeur de la
rédaction de france inter merci
également d'être avec nous et côté
figaro j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
cécile kusel journaliste chef adjoint du
service macroéconomie france est donc
grande spécialiste du budget bonjour
c'est bonjour bonjour guillaume perrault
vous êtes journaliste aux pages débats
du figaro merci à tous les quatre merci
aux internautes qui nous ont déjà
rejoint alors le budget est faut-il
écouter françois hollande de séoul il se
rappelle donc aux bons souvenirs de son
successeur
et ce en plein début de discussions sur
le budget à l'assemblée nationale entre
l'ancien et le nouveau président les
histoires d'argent tourne toujours mal
on regarde françois hollande ce n'est
plus une pique contre la politique d'
emmanuel macron c'est une attaque au
bazooka
l'idée s'installe qu' il y a finalement
une fiscalité allégée pour les riches
est alourdie pour les plus modestes ou
pour les classes moyennes alors c'est la
productivité globale du pays c'est la
capacité qu'il a à se mobiliser pour son
avenir qui se trouve mise en cause
je pense qu'il est utile d'avoir une
fiscalité juste jean marc four il joue à
quoi françois lang il le veut voler la
vedette de meilleur adversaire de
emmanuel macron avec mélenchon d'abord
pour ceux qui pensaient qu'il a
leicester c'est raté je veux pas s'en
empêcher
je crois que mes quiconque connaît
françois hollande n'est pas surpris
parce que là il aime parler
donc il parle première chose deuxième
chose je suis tenté de dire qu'il a
c'est un peu une formule mais qui l'a
économique mentor et politiquement
raisons économiques mentor parce que on
ne peut pas dire qu'on puisse porter à
son crédit une relance spectaculaire de
la croissance et de l'emploi lors de son
quinquennat
donc il n'est pas nécessairement le
mieux placé pour donner des leçons
emmanuel macron politiquement raison
dans le sens où quand il alerte sur le
fait que attention par exemple classes
moyennes il soulève un point intéressant
pour l'instant on va dire politiquement
emmanuel macron tient en partie parce
qu'une proportion importante de la
population dans les classes moyennes qui
qui adhèrent à son raisonnement
ça ne durera peut-être pas éternellement
donc il faut qu'il fasse attention
effectivement il peut pas s'empêcher de
donner des coups de griffes
après les la volée le groupement que l'a
fait emmanuel macron dans son interview
à tf1 et il ne pouvait répondre enfin la
dispute de date pas d'hier
en fait il faut jamais oublier que c'est
françois hollande qui a porté macro sur
les fonts baptismaux à l'elysée d'abord
au ministère ensuite et que macro a été
un peu le fils naturel de la finance et
de françois hollande
après il y a eu rupture à la demeure
parce que ma croix bien montré sur le
fond et sur la forme qu'il entendait se
détacher et en plus de ça de son
prédécesseur et il n'a pas manqué de
lancer des piques dont que françois
hollande lui répond je suis pas s'il
faut accorder plus d'importance que ça à
la voie de la résistance à séoul bien
jouer politiquement nous disait jean
marc four vous êtes d'accord bien non je
trouve ça un peu mesquin de saisir
l'occasion d'une conférence à l'étranger
pour régler des comptes il aurait pu
attendre au moins d'être en france c'est
sûr qu'après ce que nous a dit qu'il
n'avait pas écouté en tout cas il a fait
dire qu'il n'avait pas écouté le
l'interview démarche femmes oui le
croire à qui et qui voudra et
il ya quand même y avait quand même
jadis en effet mais c'est certainement
comme vous l'avez dit un réflexe du
monde d'avant un usage qui était quand
même de s'abstenir à l'étranger de ce
genre de polémique déjà été oui je vous
savez j'ai compris parfois on a tous des
souvenirs de manuels d'histoire
churchill quand il était à l'étranger il
a fait un discours à fulton dans le
missouri qui a marqué l'histoire et
hollande lui l'aura s'applique sur macro
en corée du sud on l'a changé d'époque
on va je ne suis pas sûr que ça qu'il en
sortira particulièrement grandi c'est
que vous l on va le voir sur le fond le
mais sur la forme
vous rejoignez ce que il a raison ou
tort mais sur la forme c'est de bonne
guerre parce qu'effectivement façon
emmanuel macron l'attaqué fait c'est
directement dimanche soir moi je trouve
le problème c'est surtout au fond c'est
à dire ce qu'il dit est faux
voilà c'est que en fait alourdies pour
les plus modestes et les classes
moyennes c'est pour être confond donc où
il comme un problème qu'on peut raconter
aussi au n'importe quoi mais
effectivement ça léger pour les plus
riches mais la fiscalité n'est en aucune
façon alourdies pour les classes
moyennes et les plus modestes au
contraire il ya un allègement de la taxe
d'habitation et pour on est contre la
bascule entre la sage et les cotisations
salariales ça fait baisser il ya une
étude qui montre voilà que ce il ya une
place sociale qui voit sa fiscalité
alourdie pour le quinquennat si on en
reste aujourd'hui c'est ceux du 9e déçu
ça c'est les gens ont des candidats
populations m'ont dit on dit partie et
c'est ce qu'ils sont l'avant-dernier
plus aux plus riches
donc en fait c'est les avant-derniers
plus riches qui sait concilier dans le
figaro a cédé place royale c'est les
classes moyennes supérieures qui vont
qui vont voir leur pouvoir d'achat
baisser de 0 2 point sont heureux d'être
2% sur le quinquennat tout le reste y
gagne après on peut ne pas croire les
chiffres on peut
mais on peut aussi raconter n'importe
quoi à longueur de journée voilà c'est
moi c'est ça qui me choque vous
trouverez andré bercoff emmanuel macron
n'a eu de cesse depuis l'été de se
démarquer et de ne surtout pas être le
fils spirituel de françois hollande
c'est il a réussi maintenant bon il a
réussi il faut attendre des résultats je
m'inscris tout petit peu en fait lorsque
vous avez dit vous avez dit que seuls
seront touchés les classes supérieures
et les autres non attendez les retraités
à 1400 euros par mois est ce que c'est
vraiment des sommes folles et ce sont
des jeunes à quelque chose qui se passe
à dire que c'est les classes moyennes et
les classes modestes en aucun cas
vraiment il ya une rose de la prime
d'activité voilà il ya une désolation
sur les retraites devrait songer je veux
dire qu'il faut pas traiter les choses à
ne pas avoir tout le reste c'est
l'ensemble du paysage qu'il faut voir
moi je vais vous dire les agriculteurs à
350 euros par mois un tiers des
agriculteurs etc
il ya quand même du pain sur la planche
l'on peut pas le reprocher un maquereau
mais dire que tout va bien et que les
baguettes magiques dangers associés les
provinces c'est pas du tout doucement
légèrement en baisse doit être méditée
chose que je n'ai pas dit je n'ai pas du
tout dit que tout allait bien je vous ai
dit la critique de françois hollande 10
ans mais lourd dit que c'est bon c'est
ont alourdi la fiscalité pour les
volumes modestes et les classes moyennes
effectivement à vraiment leur hôtel où
je m'étais que ça dure jamais que
françois hollande a été le seul vrai
emploi fictif de ces cinq dernières
années qui nous a rejoint qui il dit pas
si c'était un emploi fictif ou pas mais
dit françois hollande devrait adopter un
droit de réserve et être plus silencieux
effectivement je revenais sur l'idée il
peut pas s'empêcher de parler il ce que
vous soulignez les uns les autres
on l'a vu il veut notamment apparaître
enfin pouvoir éventuellement peser sur
le ps
il arrive à la politique et justement
c'est tout ça fait quand même pas très
ça montre pas une grande élévation je
suis désolé mais normalement un ancien
président soit se consacre à des
désordres pour le long terme et en
sciences voilà il ya sa fondation certes
et les anciens présidents aux états unis
en général essaie de prendre de la
hauteur de réfléchir à l'avenir
ou alors je reprenais l'exemple de
churchill vous me direz que je place la
barre très haut mais quand il a été
battu sèchement par les travaillistes en
1945 il a pris son bâton de pèlerin il a
fait des conférences aux états unis ou
en suisse et à cette occasion il a
alerté sur le rideau de fer qui était en
train de se dresser
savait il s'est hissé e-santé y sont des
d'ailleurs pas ça n'a d'ailleurs pas
rencontré le soutien des des
sympathisants de droite qui filme en
longs sèchement remercié à la primaire
donc à mon avis quand c'est terminé vaut
mieux tourner la page et prendre de la
hauteur que de s'engluer dans les
polémiques quotidienne mais c'est
françois hollande
pardon de le dire et de le répéter mais
c'est françois hollande dire que
françois hollande m commenté
d'aucuns diraient certains commentateurs
à meilleur commentateur qu'acteur c'est
sûr ils aiment commentait il a toujours
aimé commenter il aime parler ils aiment
discuter évidemment avec les
journalistes tout le monde le sait et il
aime commenter malabo qui commente je
vais vous faites pas des chats et des
chiens donc mais il est bien sûr que
tous les journalistes ont des souvenirs
il était extrêmement excessive quand il
était premier secrétaire du ps je me
souviens de journées parlementaires à
nos verts il ya plus de dix ans mais
voilà il était tellement pourvoyeur de
d'anecdotes et d' analyse intéressante
d'ailleurs très intéressante et
intelligente que parfois on avait
l'impression qu'il aurait fallu co signé
les papiers qui il essayait d'orienter
et on avait effectivement le spectacle
cette espèce de jubilation qui avait
chez lui à commenter ou a aussi montré
ses talents d'imitateur s'éteint c'est
une de ses facettes il imite très bien
les gens vieillissent et très bien
flatter les journalistes
les maîtres il les mettre dans sa poche
en tout cas on a aussi vu les limites de
cet état d'esprit parce qu'une fois
qu'il est devenu président il a continué
ce qui avait fait son succès juste il
alors
alors qu'en fait on attendait tout objet
de lui parce qu'il était que ça il
mettait que s'endetter commentateurs de
sa propre inaction un ex-président
devrais pas dire ça c'est ce qu'on est
en train de dire aujourd'hui mais en
fait le problème de françois hollande ça
a toujours été ça cela dit je vais très
bien que la politique est une rupture
malheureusement même quand on n'est plus
là on est toujours là tant qu'on n'est
pas mort à part un cheval plat ou par
crise cardiaque
on est là on va regarder mitterrand les
trois fois où on l'a laissé pour mort
sur le terrain et il est revenu
c'est ça la question de se voir poser
vos internautes du figaro était est
toujours d'ailleurs françois hollande
peut-il revenir dans le débat politique
et la réponse est non à 89 % sur quinze
mille votants pour le moment donc
effectivement une plutôt une une amie
unanimité mais ça dépend aussi comment
on comprend la question puisque dans le
petit il ya deux de compréhension
possible
je crois que les enquêtes montrent que
l'on enseigne ne souhaite pas être par
des dates cause au delà des lecteurs
internautes du figaro que les français
ne souhaitent pas qu'il revienne ma vie
politique je pense que les enquêtes le
démontrent assez largement
oui mais de peser sur le débat d en
tirer les ficelles de ce que sera là lui
l'envié c'est nous avons mari qui nous
dit que cinq mois plus tard que ton dire
qu emmanuel macron est toujours le fils
de hollande qui en a partiellement
répondu à cette question
sur le fond on va l'aborder health un
budget pour les riches un budget
équilibré un budget qui fait encore la
part belle à la dépense publique
pour eric woerth ancien ministre de
nicolas sarkozy est président de la
commission des finances ce budget c'est
avant tout une usine à gaz
écoutez le c'est la gesticulation
fiscales et sociales
et on se demande surtout à quoi ça sert
à quoi ça sert de prendre comme ça on
dirait que les fonctionnaires en leur
disant vous gagnez trop à partir de 1200
sais plus si c'est 1200 1350 d'euros
vous gagnez trop il faut réduire votre
train de vie parce qu'il faut bien que
les actifs gagner un peu d'argent
à quoi ça sert que sont les vois ça va
bouger
un dixième de point de croissance dans
notre pays en rien mais strictement rien
c'est injuste et ça ne sert à rien c'est
sickouz elle c'est de la gesticulation
bien il ya en tout cas je pense qu'ils
sont pas très à l'air ça c'est très à
l'aise certains nerfs sur yasser car
certains points certaines mesures sur
les sf et sur la taxation des revenus
financiers
la fameuse flat tax c'est des mesures
qu'ils auraient voulu faire ils n'ont
jamais fait donc voilà donc je suis anna
qui l'on cherche là dessus sur lui et ça
faisait quand même pas très à l'aise
bon ça c'est un peu voilà après la
bascule entre la cg toute cette
patrouille âge effectivement ça assez
complexe et pas l'idée s'est allégée à
pour le coût du travail bon c'est pas
c'est pas l'un comme un décor c'est pas
limpide pour le commun des mortels
ces impôts des mots simples accordé ça
fait un gain de pouvoir d'achat pour les
actifs très bien guillaume n'est pas
celle d'eric woerth et les autres oui il
ya un mois je
c'est vrai à laon les biens de bien sûr
bien sûr binelli nos pays ne peuvent que
dire
il va pas assez loin il faut et eux et
en rajouter en disant par exemple il
aurait fallu abrogé lisf complètement ce
que d'ailleurs je trouve je trouve tout
à fait eu tout à fait sensé ce qu'il y à
un paradoxe dans cette es sfc que macro
ont réussi à mécontenter beaucoup de
monde
les une partie des couches populaires
qui sont heurtés par cette mesure
il donne aussi un argument à gauche
contre lui et en même temps il rend fou
de rage les ceux qui vont rester
assujettis à l isf et qui paradoxalement
sont souvent moins fortunés ils sont
visés bien sûr mais si on me paierait
pas les sf c'est entendu mais ils sont
pas pour autant riches entre les est
riche il ya des nuances et donc on a le
sentiment qui veut promouvoir un modèle
de réussite sociale qui finalement ne
peut pas
fédérer beaucoup parce que ça s'adresse
nécessairement à des gens trop peu
nombreux et ça c'est un problème parce
que ça se détache trop trop
ostensiblement des des traditions
françaises où il ya déjà le rapport
catholique compliquée avec l'argent qui
fait qu'on a cette phase ce fameux tabou
de l'usf
on peut aussi puiser argumente
économiquement sur la nécessité de le
supprimer bon c'est toujours assez
toujours des difficiles on a vu à quel
point gouvernement et paraît tout à fait
démunis face aux attaques de président
des riches
tous les députés en marche à l'assemblée
quand nous avait présenté comme des
entrepreneurs dynamiques de la société
civile vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir mais je les ai pas beaucoup vu je
ne sais pas beaucoup entendus pour
défendre cette répondre aux attaques qui
sont adressés sur sur macro et
finalement le la tradition française qui
veut quand même que un travailleur
indépendant qui a bien réussi dans sa
vie cabossée comme un damné avec ça avec
son épouse par exemple et qui se
retrouvent assujettis à l isf et que
normalement quand il est propriétaire
d'un bel appartement il peut pas espérer
arriver plus loin socialement il se sent
dans le champ de vision de la réussite
de mâcon c'est ça qui est très étonnant
du coup il est vexé ordre c'est c'est ça
une demi mesure la suppression partielle
d'heuliez sf qui fait beaucoup de
mécontents
ça rejoint un peu ce que je disais tout
à l'heure sur la distinction entre
politique et économique
il ya un risque politique que pour ces
raisons là même à court terme à près
d'un autre côté il y à un calcul
économique dont seul l'avenir nous dira
s'il est pertinent pas c'est la fameuse
théorie du ruissellement enfin lui ils
appellent ça premier de cordée m'enfin
appelez ça comme vous voulez c'est à peu
près la même idée c'est que en exonérant
tout ça on va faire redescendre
l'investissement en cascade avec les
valoriser oui et que c'est que donc ça
va porter ses fruits économiquement dans
donkey on a bien compris un an et demi
ou deux ans bon il faut que ça tienne
politiquement d'ici là aussi s'ils
tentaient que ce calcul économique soit
pertinent mais ça l'avenir nous le dira
oui on a juste mari qui compte suivre
après perso
jeudi marie qui s'inquiète qui
s'interroge eric woerth avec trois
points d'interrogation quel résultat en
cinq ans la droite d'étape il ya un
problème avec emmanuel macron c'est que
à un moment donné il s'avance et puis il
fait deux pas en avant un pas en arrière
je m'explique sur l'histoire y est
voyons on parle et qui se dé qu'ils se
sont vraiment se séparer de son
prédécesseur ont en tout cas qui devrait
marquer la voix hors moi j'étais
absolument frappé il a recommencé à
parler de date pour l'inversion de la
courbe du chômage
vous vous rappelez quand même piège du
syndrome hollande 2013 lui des dents un
ennemi deux ans vous allez voir ce qui
est extraordinaire parce qu'il sait ça
va quand il est tout sauf bête ils sont
bidons
l'explication c'est qu'à un moment donné
je crois qu'il ya de vraiment ce
problème ce piège il est obligé de
parler d' on ne s'explique etc
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il l'a fait à
comment la pression et pourrait reposer
donc est finie et finit par dire écoutez
je vais être obligé deux il y as a par
exemple il ya aussi tout ce problème de
cette france périphérique vous savez de
bon tout ça est en fait il est obligé et
moi je crois que je reviens pas à la
forme et mais je moi ce qui m'a frappé
c'est que on est obligé en recevant une
minute d'aborder tous les sujets en fait
peut pas aborder tous les sujets d'avoir
la moitié et haineux n'approfondit pas
donc on est resté voyez quand vous dites
que vous avez tout à fait raison
l'avenir dira ce qu'il se passe mais
pourquoi ont-ils des engagements moi
j'ai été très frappée de ça j'ai dit ah
voilà le hollande sort de ce cadre un
titre à son propre piège dans sa cellule
il n'a pas fait aussi sur guillaume
perrault par exemple on a on a c'est pas
le sujet du budget mais c'est le
l'histoire des clandestins délinquants
qui promet des expulsés alors qu'on sait
que c'est plus compliqué esquissée pas
aussi un peu là en disant que c'est un
petit peu le fier à bras en disant
j'espère mettre dehors demain qu'il a
quand même dit que ça serait compliqué
aussi je crois il a eu une formule
poldi décent il est quand même obligé de
réagir à la polémique qui est née de
marseille va faire de marseille sauf que
ça fait dix ans que vous le savez a su
personne n'a rien fait la norme
naturelle mais après sur deus avait vu
que n'ai je ne peux pas reprocher macron
d'annoncer un effort dans ce domaine il
y avait là méme effectivement maintenant
je pense que l'opinion va être beaucoup
plus exigeante sur les questions
techniques
c'est à dire les fameux laisser passer
consulaire est ce que vraiment la
jurisprudence européenne et est trop
contraignante en tout cas est ce qu'elle
est appliquée de façon trop tatillonne
par la france ou par les juridictions
françaises alors que nos voisins serait
un aura une interprétation peu vient
d'être envoyée aujourd'hui au préfet
pour leur rappeler justement et les
inciter je crois a effectivement
expulser les délinquants et n'oublions
jamais que 3 % sont expulsés
actuellement 3%
donc faut pas oublier que c'est très
compliqué mais le problème des pays des
complexes on le sait effectivement
toujours voyez julien qui nous dit
s'interroge comme nous pourquoi se
mettent ils m'attaqueront dans lequel du
timing sur les résultats devaient t-il
esquivé la question
alors il ya un autre sujet dans les
affaires économiques budget et qui fait
beaucoup parler c'est celui de sai de ce
projet de ben bonus malus appliqués aux
entreprises
l'idée de taxer celles qui ont largement
recours aux contrats courts c'est-à-dire
de type cdd
le patronat ne veut pas en entendre
parler
regardez ce qu'en dit pierre gattaz le
président du medef c'était ce matin on a
déjà montré que c'était une absurdité
c'est une à nice m une accord
professionnel de 2013 qui à surtaxer les
cdd
on a vu que ça n'avait eu aucune leur
apporter grand-chose sa part apporté
grand chose donc on a supprimé et les
accords que nous avons signés soit son
chômage au printemps dernier avec les
partenaires sociaux
eh bien on est tous d'accord ça ne sert
à rien de taxer des contrats courts ça
affaiblit des filières des secteurs très
porteurs d'emplois très demandeur
d'emploi je parle de la restauration je
parle du commerce par de l'hôtellerie je
parle de l'événementiel
je marque pour il a raison c'est un gars
tu as ça ne sert à rien de taxer les
contrats courts il ya un sujet sur les
contrats courent on peut pas nier qu'il
ya un sujet c'est la première chose ils
ont quand même doublé en 15 ans 7% des
tout d'abord aujourd'hui 87 % des
embauches et un sujet on peut pas nier
non plus que dans certains endroits il
ya un comportement qui est limite je
suis sûr qu'on en connaît tous par
expérience personnelle c'est-à-dire un
contrat qui pourrait par exemple durer
deux mois mais on va faire quinze jours
puis on va arrêter quelques jours pour
voir comment ces quinze jours alors
qu'en fait on pourrait faire de moi dès
le départ donc ça existe donc on peut
pas nier que le sujet existe
après est ce que une modification de
cette taxation avec ce système du bonus
malus et efficace effectuant jusqu'à
présent ça jamais vraiment marché enfin
en tout cas dans le système français ça
jamais vraiment marché parce qu aux
etats unis avait quelque chose qui s'en
rapproche un peu ça s'appelle xpérience
writing je crois et ça marche un petit
peu comme ça
donc faut peut-être regarder plus
précisément comment font les américains
j'avoue que je ne suis pas assez
compétent sur le sujet ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'en france ça n'a jamais
vraiment porté ses fruits cl ça j'ai
effectivement ça a jamais porté ses
fruits puisque le bonus souvent aussi
parce que la taxe sur taxation des
contrats courts étaient assez limitées
donc du coup ça a rapporté 70 millions
d'euros ce n'était pas de quoi c'est pas
du tout dissuasif c'est à dire que dans
les 87 % dans gauche qui soit en cdd ce
qui se passe c'est que c'est en nombre
d'embauchés en fait on a des cdd de plus
en plus courts en france depuis une
quinzaine d'années donc sur deux ou
trois jours une semaine etc et qui
multiplié les embauches du couvent donc
on vous êtes embauché quatre fois dans
le mois on voudrait embaucher une fois
si vous faites quatre cdd d'une semaine
donc il ya vraiment un problème ils ont
essayé de le résoudre dans leur dernière
convention d'assurance chômage en mars
parce qu'en fait il ya tous ces abus
parce qu'aussi l'assurance chômage
indemnisé les foyers pour casser
d'aucuns n'ont rien il ya un réel
problème
après ce qu'on peut craindre moi je
crois surtout sur cette taxe sur le
système n'a proposé par le gouvernement
c'est une usine à gaz pour un truc super
compliqué pour arriver
à mesure et qui est vertueux qui n'est
pas qui abuse qui abuse pas ça peut être
quand même assez compliqué comme système
du jour on retrouve tout à fait ce qui
nous attend ce qui vient d'être dit
j'ajouterai simplement ce paradoxe c'est
qu'on nous dit qu aux etats unis
ce système fonctionne mieux est ce que
ce serait parce que paradoxalement le
licenciement est beaucoup plus simple
est qu'il ya une économie beaucoup plus
libérale qui fait que quand pour une
fois l'état intervient il est plus
facile de mesurer le le l'impact d'une
d'une intervention étatique dans le
fonctionnement des communes du marché du
travail je sais pas mais c'est quand
même assez curieux de se voir opposer
l'exemple américain en 10 ans chez eux
ça marche
merci parce que justement l'exemple
amérique le fondement et la vienne n'a
rien d'un autre en fait tout se passe
pour nous c'est comme s'il y avait une
espèce de cabrioles sais c'est pas de
danse avec les stars c'est danse avec
les stars sur un filet de sécurité de
filet sécurité c'est l'état vous avez
parlé effectivement de l'assurance
chômage qui vient compenser les choses
et par les eaux si c'est vrai c'est à
dire allons-y essayons faisant des
cabrioles et puis en tout cas l'état
payera l'état sauf que c'est nous vous
rappelons que c'est la phrase hollande
ça ne fait rien l'état paiera quelque
part on a l'impression que l'on se dit
allez on va tenter des choses ça c'est
un marché ça va marcher mais de toute
façon on va se retrouver le sur
l'assiette des dépenses publiques et
quelque part c'est très malsain
autre sujet c'est aujourd'hui le 30e
journée mondiale du refus de la misère
emmanuel macron a reçu des associations
à déjeuner aujourd'hui à l'elysée puis
l'a ensuite visité une crèche qui
accueille des enfants défavorisés
n'est-ce qu'un passage obligé pour un
président le reste du temps les
politiques tient-il à distance se
tient-il à distance des pauvres la
présidente d'akd et des cas remontent
claire et dont était ce matin sur rtl
elle en parlait dans notre inconscient
collectif on a cette idée que qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait pour être dans cette
situation là et ils font pas grand chose
elle s'en sortir la pauvre phobie c'est
le terme qu'on a utilisées mais noah mes
débuts dans le mouvement il ya 25 ans
quand j'étais comme ça en face de
familles en situation de précarité mais
j'étais super mal à l'aise j'avais peur
de dire des bêtises c'est tellement loin
de mon monde et et c'est ça qu'on veut
aussi il faut que le politique bouge
mais il faut aussi que la société se
rencontrent et moi jabouille je veux je
dois vous dire que j'avais peur elle
parle à ses caches la présidente d'akd
et des 40
andré bercoff et cette pauvre phobie
elle nous touche tous aux politiques ce
journal il faut pas très heureux mais la
cage aux folles comme disait philippe le
ray ça va moi je vais vous dire ce qui
me gêne vraiment qu'on ait besoin de
faire une journée
qu'est ce que c'est une journée une
journée de la femme une journée pour
ceux ci une journée pour cela la misère
c'est un c'est un problème permanent il
ya le traité de façon permanente que ce
soit pour les outils pour les autres
déjà ça franchement c'est pour moi assez
obscènes
deuxièmement et surtout oui il y à il ya
un problème mais le problème encore une
fois c'est de le traiter à la base et ne
pas le traiter comme un moment donné à
l'est médiatiquement hovasse en
appareils on va faire un téléthon
non il y a quelque chose de grave est
bien traitons le traitons le alors bon
c'est pas on va pas faire voir paris a
qu'à faut qu'on
mais je veux dire on s'est très très
bien le problème du salaire médian en
france et c est ce qu on peut changer
les choses en profondeur ou pas on
attend de voir le terme
non je n'aime pas le terme en effet
parce qu'à une course à la phobie chacun
veut être victime est donc c'est une
grande concurrence victimaire on a
l'impression qu'à 65 millions de
personnes victimes de quelque chose en
france
j'ajouterai que on peut dater
l'émergence de cette sensibilité avec
autour des grandes causes consensuel
évidemment la misère qui peut qui peut
défendre la misère en tout le monde
personne n'ose critiquer ce genre
d'initiative c'est dans les années 80 et
ses concurrents de la la fatigue des
grandes idéologies collective
on a vu ce thème de la nouvelle pauvreté
émergeaient au tout à la toute fin du
septennat giscard et se traduire
politiquement pendant la présidentielle
de 88 dans la lettre de mitterrand à
tous les français qui le dit et on que
son instrument de campagne il ya un long
passage sur la misère et mitterrand dit
j'ai visité un centre emmaüs ou jus
l'abbé pierre quelque chose comme ça et
raconte à peu près ce qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est vraiment significatif
du de l'apparition des grandes causes
consensuel comme substitut à une
idéologie collective pour mobilisent
la société et du terme nouveaux pauvres
c'était un nouveau pauvre
c'était un peu plus anciens parce qu'il
y avait eu un rapport à la toute fin des
années giscard envers 80 80
miraculeusement juste avant la
présidentielle qui lançait l'expression
nouveau qu il faut pas oublier les
restos du coeur oui à l'époque 80 je
serai je suis un peu avant voilà 85
important allez moi je vais défendre
claire hédon
moi non plus j'aime pas les formules
avec faux billets pareil en même temps
elle soulève un point qui est
intéressant c'est à dire qu'elle qu'elle
et son raisonnement il est de dire les
élites
en résumé ne connaissent pas cet univers
là parce que ce n'est pas le leur tout
simplement voilà il ya eu dans ce cas
des hôtesses et donc quand vous ne
connaissez pas un univers vous c'est
presque mécanique vous avez tendance à
en avoir peur c'est ça qu'elle
expliquait elle n'a pas tout à fait tort
son raisonnement n'est pas complètement
erroné moi non plus j'aime pas le terme
forme pauvre phobie mais sur ce point là
je trouve qu'elle n'a pas tout à fait
tort ensuite ce qui est intéressant
c'est sujets de fond que le sujet de
fond c'est la pauvreté en france mans
alors sur ça il ya des choses quand même
qu'il faut à mon avis qu'il faut pointer
la première chose c'est que le ya
évidemment trop de pauvres en france
d'accord nous par rapport à la moyenne
européenne moins pire que la plupart des
autres si on prend les chiffres ocde
on est sur 14 pour cent la population en
france un seul ont d'ailleurs de ligue 1
ont paru aujourd'hui
mise à jour par l'insee le cdo et en
europe c'est très en dessous de
l'allemagne le royaume uni l'espagne
l'italie tout ça c'est très au dessus en
proportion de la population
en revanche ce que vous avez en france
c'est des quartiers qui cumule la totale
c'était et ça c'est l'échec de quarante
40 ans de politique de la ville
politique de la ville et amy et c'est ce
que je dis c'est l'échec de milliards
dépensés le tonneau des danaïdes
et là vous avez les quartiers où il ya
plus rien là pour le coup alors ça c'est
un c'est un sujet plus précis et plus
compliqués qui mériterait pour le mans
qui est une vraie politique de la ville
on m'offrait une excellente transition
va revoir claire hédon toujours la
présidente d'akd et guermantes qui sur
le fond avec l'âme une complète refonte
du logement social
et vous savez quoi on est
majoritairement vous à nous avec des
familles à qui on dit vous êtes trop
pauvre pour bénéficier du logement
social
il faut une réforme complète du logement
social et là dessus on pourrait
rejoindre le gouvernement n'est
absolument contre cette baisse des 5
euros des appels à part ça ça vous a
choqué rêvant de s'y met 5 euros c'est
énorme quand on est dans les situations
de précarité donc qu'est-ce qu'on envoie
comme message
en revanche maintenant tout ce qu'on dit
il faudrait fixer le loyer le montant du
loyer en fonction des revenus de la
famille est là elle pour accéder au
logement social
emma une utopie assas au québec un
problème c'est alors en région
parisienne et dans les grandes
métropoles clairement il ya d'énormes
problèmes de logement en france assez
évident de mal
de sans abri ni il suffit de se promener
je vous invite dans le quartier de notre
quartier le soir vous allez voir c'est
spectaculaire
admis des facultés à briller ils dorment
tous les noms des galeries lafayette je
vous invite t elle à 10 ans le soir vous
allez vous voilà à nouveau très policé
c'est assez vrai c'est le stadium
voilà c'était très très frappant est
très très dur à voir mais oui et donc
effectivement la politique du logement
mais ça on le sait elle est assez
inefficace il ya 18 milliards dead l'apn
voilà c'est au nom des danaïdes 1 pour
un résultat très très mitigé et
effectivement beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes en difficulté ou des personnes
qui travaillent aussi ils n'ont pas
accès au logement social
jean louis valentin pilates nous a
rejoints valentin qui scrute les réseaux
sociaux pour nous qu'on soit vous allez
nous dire un peu ce qu'on est con ce
qu'on dit de cette question et vous
soulignez deux tendances apparemment qui
se dessine qui se dégage
oui c'est ça exactement de tendance
notamment une que vous partagez tous
autour de ce plateau celle du terme qui
est détesté des internautes vraiment le
mot pauvres aux phobies il le déteste
vraiment il ne l'apprécient pas du tout
on commence donc du coup avec ce tweet
de jct et une phobie de plus une somme
on est un petit parce que sur ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur la cage
aux folles
andré ou encore tasse andard un
barbarisme linguistique et idéologique
tout comme l'islamophobie ciom un petit
pique envers les associations aussi
également vu qu'elle utilise ce terme de
tata les assurent les associations
ferait bien de ne pas donner de leçons
les français donnent beaucoup et c'est
souvent ceux qui on peut d'ailleurs nous
dit ata mais c'est aussi l'occasion pour
les internautes en fait de s'adresser au
chef de l'état avec pomme s'est
notamment qui nous dit macron et son
plan pauvreté alors qu'il mène une
politique qui crée toujours plus de
pauvreté et d'inégalité c'est pathétique
dit il on natale yann également qui
parle de clichés revoyons nos clichés et
changeons de regard sur la pauvreté
il faut en finir avec la pauvre phobie
je terminerai avec ce commentaire sur le
site du figaro de l'amiral du 60 et qui
pose une question
intéressante il ya un peu plus
pragmatique au lieu de se lamenter sur
les pauvres
il faudrait se demander déjà pourquoi et
comment on en est arrivé à lise j'ajoute
le commentaire de chantal faire une
journée de la pauvreté c'est honteux
un autre débat qui agite beaucoup ces
derniers jours c'est évidemment la
sphère aux états unis et la déferlante
provoqué par le hashtag balances ton
port qui ne s'arrête plus sur twitter
des noms de harceleur supposés sont
balancés sur la toile à la délation cris
les uns une salutaire libération de la
parole se félicite les autres c'est le
cas de brigitte macron qui l'a dit
publiquement
une position qui est exprimée aussi par
la garde des sceaux nicole belloubet
c'était ce matin sur france inter on les
écoute toutes les deux peut-être que ce
sera un mal pour un bien
il y a dans le mot porc et dans le mot
balance il y a finalement de deux
notions qui ne sont pas celles qu'on
voudrait voir régir notre société les
termes choisis sont volontairement
choquant mais si cela sans doute qu'il
ya aussi inciter à libérer la part
guillaume perrault 7
le grand déballage où c'est
effectivement une libération de la
parole écoutez si ça reste un témoignage
qui ne désigne pas une personne qui ne
nomme pas les personnes je peux
comprendre qu'on ait envie de partager
de partager ces faits si en revanche on
nomme les gens là étaient faits je
trouve cela je trouve ça extrêmement
dangereux je trouve ça exactement parce
qu'il ya quelque chose s'appelle la
présomption d'innocence je suis surpris
que la garde des sceaux n'en parlent pas
peut-être qu'elle en a parlé à un autre
moment dans un autre extrait de
l'interview
enfin la la présomption d'innocence
endroit francs en droit pénal
ça veut dire quelque chose et la
diffamation ça existe aussi et on peut
tout à fait être victime d'une
accusation calomnieuse donc ces réseaux
sociaux fassent cette espèce de
déferlantes sur ce plan-là m'inspire de
la méfiance andré bercoff juste on a vu
hier bruno le maire qui a été au plus de
grain mea culpa en quelques heures je
n'aime pas la délation c'est pas mon
truc
et ensuite il est revenue sur sa en
disant ah mais extrêmement communal le
maire
il a montré sa ductilité et ce sous bsd
chine dans des circonstances très
diverses
non mais je veux dire problème il n'est
pas là le problème est juste et cartons
atout fabuleux paysages dans sa totalité
il ya toujours eu et ce n'est pas une
excuse une explication est toujours une
omerta est une mafia là dessus et y
compris et mais qui dit mafia dit omerta
et y compris par ses histoires
d'harcèlement sexuel
rappelons-nous la garde rapprochée de
dominique strauss-kahn dont tout le
monde le petit monde savait que c'était
un prédateur j'ai pas dit un violeur
mais après d'acteurs et dont on a
soigneusement caché ça alors des années
le petit milieu savez les autres il
n'avait pas à savoir weinstein c'est la
même chose pour dans le milieu de
hollywood hollywood c'est la clé des
rêves c'est le fantasme formidable
cinéma mondial
donc oui il s'éteint c'est un type qui
est pas bien on le sait on l'a entendu
vraiment et on l'entend
moi je suis plus du tout hollywood quand
je sais faire des reportages ont parlé à
cinq ans de harvey weinstein et de ces
partis
2 c'est parti je parle au niveau des
surprises parties comme on peut dire et
bien d'en parler personne disait rien
donc vous avez ça d'abord omerta et les
gens accepté et les gens se plier bon
aujourd'hui ans explose et moi je
rejoins juste qu'ils en paieront les
histoires celles non à partir ne m'en
vous donner des noms là ça devient du
ressort de la justice et moi je dis que
les une française qui ont donné des noms
pourquoi ne l'attaquent en justice des
pauvres sagan est bien sûr à chaque fois
on nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
elle a effectivement parlé aussi de
présenter bien sûr je pense que ce
qu'elle voulait dire surtout c'est que
c'était salutaire dans le sens où la
parole se libère vitesse ça veut dire ça
veut dire que comme le disait andré
bercoff à l'instant il ya une omerta et
qu'il est grand temps que la parole se
libère un peu plus et que et que que la
perspective se retourne si vous voulez
puisqu'on dit enfin selon les enquêtes
malgré tout que c'est à peu près une
femme sur cinq qui dans le courant de sa
vie professionnelle est l'objet
d'harcèlement c'est énorme
c'était énorme donc oui moi je trouve
que c'est salutaire et je suis je
partage sans barguigner ce point de vue
maintenant il ya un autre sujet dans le
sujet et on l'évoqué à l'instant si
cette question de la 2e on va dire de la
délation ou de la diffamation de ces
risques là alors moi je vais avancé une
autre explication à l'attitude de bruno
le maire peut-être qu'effectivement ces
caractéristiques du monomère mais
au-delà de ça je pense que ça dit
quelque chose d'un peu plus profond sur
la société française
je pense qu'on a je dis ça parce que je
dise est dû
du haut de mon expérience britannique
d'avoir vécu plusieurs années la société
britannique a un rapport très différent
cette chose là je la société française
est très marqué sur ces questions-là de
c'est bon c'est mon analyse par la
période de vichy par le fait que dès
l'instant où vous dites vous montrer
quelqu'un du doigt c'est perçu comme
collabos donc quand mot délation quand
corbeau et ça on a une relation à sa qui
est là où
al'inverse les britanniques et le name
and shame regarde mais c'est parce que
pour le sol et la culture vous avez
raison mais c'est aussi la culture
protestante que la juste un élément de
gaulle occasion vous appelez les
britanniques voient ça comme un acte de
citoyenneté
quand il vous explique soeur et vous
vous écartez les mesures dangereuses et
vous dites mais comment ça de la
citoyenneté de montrer le voisin mais
absolument monsieur si je vois que son
voisin est en train de frapper son
enfant je dois le dénoncer c'est un acte
citoyen de solidarité avec la société
ses valeurs nous on a un rapport à ça
qui est extrêmement différent et je
pense que l'épisode le maire quelques
pas et une sorte d'avatar 2 semaines
dans cette relation tous formidables
parce que pour une fois une transition
absolument tout trouvé avec la culture
protestante le mot dans le modèle anglo
saxon pour régis debray qui était hier
soir l'invitée dès lundi du figaro
lors d'une conférence intitulée la
civilisation européenne aux défis du
nouveau monde
il s'agit d'une nouvelle manifestation
du puritanisme du nez au protestantisme
dit il regardez cette idée d'être pas
qu'il faut une vertueux pour faire de la
politique
excusez moi dans notre tradition ça
n'existe pas ça n'était pas contre
simple raison qu'il a fossé entre le
privé et le public donc on ne demande
pas un homme politique s'il est gentil
avec sa femme
qu'il a des maîtresses ou pas c'est le
privé ça nous concerne pas ça s'appelle
de la laïcité un séparer de domaine
d'entremont nez aux protestants des les
domaines sont complètement interpénétrés
quoi cecelia il ya quatre ans par ans
entre le privé lui donc à la fin d'une
séparation qui te même fondamental pour
nous qui était la séparation pour aller
vite entre entre le citoyen et
l'individu andre berto vous réagissiez
on écoute a résisté jusque régis debray
comparé c'est la laïcité je vois pas ce
que la lessive à la même heure justement
ou simplement c'est utile entre
l'individu et le citoyen oui là il a
raison aux ovins le corps du roi
oui on nous mais on ne demande
absolument pas un dirigeant d'être
l'archange de l'immaculée conception
ça c'est clair en revanche s'il se
conduit comme un porc au sens vrai du
terme
est ce qu'à un moment donné il faut pas
qu'il soit sous les fourches caudines de
la morale je ne vois pas pourquoi il ne
serait pas au sous prétexte que m'étant
mais si oui je trouve qu'il ya comme une
espèce de confusion on peut avoir des
buts rsa va s'avérer comme une énorme
différence entre avoir des maîtresses
pour être fidèle ça c est que sa femme
et ses malheurs et agressées
sexuellement
rien à voir donc voilà les deux les deux
vous pouvez vous voir reprocher les la
place convoquer des 10
vos proches en haïti est ce qu'on
reproche à deskless les braises maurice
mais bien sûr mais ce que vous l'ayez
régis debray je croise et il a dit aussi
décrypté le régissent de noël voilà le
fruit de bréau locke dans la maison des
petits moyens
c'est que le regard d'autrui et est un
substitut de dieu il à dire soit dans la
culture protestante donc si on se
mettait on se mettait à nu devant les
autres cette recherche de l'an 10 par an
voilà dans les pays dans les pays
protestants alors que dans les pays
catholiques n'y a pas du tout cette
tradition là et c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelque chose de ce contrôle social de
avec l'idée que si on ment dans sa vie
privée on peut pas vous faire confiance
dans votre dans votre comportement
public qu'avant on raisonnait pas du
tout comme ça en france et que
maintenant cette tradition protestante
américaine ou scandinaves viennent
progressivement chez nous ça c'est vrai
je vois qu'il ya beaucoup plus grave
justement c'est que on est en train de
perdre peut-être céder cette chose très
française qui est la séduction les
madrigaux et ses assassins pas le viol
cette espèce d'extra ordinaire
complicité entre hommes et femmes qui se
traduisait par une est vraiment une
magnifique des jeunes esprits pas
seulement chez les écrivains etc
vous aviez la séduction aujourd'hui ça
va devenir attention nous ne manquerons
pas des censeurs ne fermons pas la porte
et nous faut quand même pas exagérer
c'est qu'elles entrent ici tu as toi non
aux états unis il est donc celle québec
voilà et ça se perd sous les coups de la
police parfois de la pensée et de la
police des moeurs va attention moi
j'espère que la société française et les
femmes et les hommes sont assez
intelligents pour trouver la limite
entre la séduction et l'agression
sexuelle
j'en suis je crois pas devenir ricains
il ya théo qui nous dit brigitte alors
il revient sur brigitte macron avec ses
propos devrait-elle s'engager sur ce
sujet sur ce sujet avoir une voix qui
porte
pourquoi pas je reviens ce que vous
disiez les uns les autres sur la
délation ça devient quand on donne des
noms et tout ça est ce qu a pas une
forme quand même d'hypocrisie parce que
le succès du hashtag balances ton port
sur twitter il est dû au fait aussi
qu'il ya des noms qui ont été données
c'est problématique effectivement mais
c'est ça qui fait qu il s'est départi
gamme de htc avant qu'il y ait lino par
exemple la seconde le journaliste
français ou autres de directeurs de
chaînes de télévision il ya eu quand
même le fait que j'ai été agressée
sexuellement et je l'attendais je
raconte
et c'est vrai que l'on merten qu'au fond
on a parlé de l'omerta l'omerta est
énorme pour bien voir qu'il ya des
femmes qui ont vraiment souffert qui ont
été traumatisés parce que si elle
parlait en disant mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes mais c'est pas vrai tu étaient
consentants c'est encore vrai dans la
rue d'ailleurs mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes tu a provoqué etc etc
donc il ya quand même cette espèce
d'extra hormis chape de plomb qui a eu
et qu'il fallait que ça sorte que vous
ne pouvez pas non plus le projet de loi
sur le harcèlement de la répression du
harcèlement de requêtes pour juste un
mot ça n'a rien à voir mais savoir c'est
la fin de la prescription uniquement de
20 ans sur les vieilleries l'allongement
du déménagement des prestations qui me
paraît fondamental inscrit par un crime
contre comme la pédophilie
vous êtes donc favorable à l'allongement
du délai pierre sinon je suis même ma
brave et il est vrai diable
pas compris ce que le texte comme pour
les cris parce que c'est un débat comme
pour les crimes contre l'humanité ont
dit pas de prescription si on met ça sur
le même plan et précisons que le projet
je vois le texte chez marlène schiappa
n'est pas un texte opportunité il
yal'affaire einstein c'est quand même
beau rappel il était dans les langues
était dans les tuyaux avancé chrome qui
tombe à ce moment-là bon d'accord c'est
mais en réalité il était en préparation
bien avant faut quand même préciser ça
moi je voudrais acheter deux choses sur
le fait que le succès de ce hashtag de
ce mot diez est quand même révélateur de
ce qu'est twitter
un double titre premièrement twitter
c'est un risque comporte cet aspect de
délation potentiel c'est quelque chose
de deux consubstantielle à ce qui ce
réseau social
et c'est une ça c'est un vrai problème
je trouve d'autre part et allant au fond
des choses
twitter est un réseau très utilisé par
les journalistes
c'est le réseau social des des
journalistes et si ça a marché c'est
parce que parce que vous avez des gens
deux médias ou de deux programmes ou
d'informations qui ont dénoncé le fait
que ça existe dans les médias et c'est
aussi pour ça que le hashtag a démarré à
fond la caisse c'est aussi pour ça le
bémol attention à tour sur de dire
twitter c'est le regard des journalistes
oui je prends pas avoir de point de vue
le journaliste je vais vous dire
l'endroit c'est une forte caisse de
résonance à l'hiver le journal endroit
où on attaque le plus de journalistes de
la presse établie c'est aussi cette
solitaire elle était études au sein du
si blé noir aussi donc voilà les deux
alors ce n'est pas forcément de nature à
faire digérer leur père et aux
automobilistes mais leur argent ne sert
pas comme on l'entend souvent à
engraisser l'état le milliard des pv
serait utilisée à plus de 90% pour la
sécurité routière
telle est la conclusion d'un rapport
commandé par le ministère de l'intérieur
en ce milliard effectivement ils les
issers pour aux 30% à entretenir les pv
en installer des nouveaux c'est bien
c'est un cercle vertueux
andré bercoff rien à dire c'est la
morale c'est très bien si vraiment les
90% ou combien vous dites 80% servent à
la sécurité routière
que demande le peuple j'aurais
personnellement je vois pas ce qu'il ya
à dire latine qui ont perdu au perron je
crois vraiment me rappeler de vieux
souvenirs de finances publiques qu'on
doit pas affecter une recette de l'état
une dépense particulière dans quel état
est dans son droit a affecté
ça va pas être la loi a précisé ça va
servir à cela ou ça va servir à ça c'est
devenu une espèce de grande cause
nationale depuis chirac qui était parti
en croisade là dessus pendant son
deuxième mandat parce qu'effectivement
les chiffres ont été à l aller chiper
les chiffres pc bon en même temps il ya
toujours le côté on est de plus en plus
surveillées ont tancé moraliser ça peut
aussi taper sur le système
mais j'admets qu'il y a un argument dans
le cas précis et de la sécurité routière
ces conseils ouais il ya l'argument oui
effectivement et je trouve de
l'efficacité de la baisse du nombre sur
les routes quand même un voile à la peur
du gendarme ça maintient dos j'ai fait
un peu de sujet qui fait aussi beaucoup
réagir c'est celui qui est connexe et
celui du des villes qui vont pouvoir à
partir du 1er janvier prochain
fixer elle même le montant des pv de
stationnement alors on l'a vu déjà les
prix s'envolent par exemple dans le
centre de paris ça sera 50 euros à lyon
60 bonsu chacun fait comme il veut c'est
c'est une façon de gagner de l'argent et
de faire rentrer de l'argent dans les
caisses c'est une vieille histoire ça
parce que à l'époque que je suivais le
budget je me rende mon rappel et ça fait
longtemps que les collectivités locales
de monde ça d'avoir la liberté td les
amants s'étaient longtemps 11 euros ce
qui n'était pas du tout dissuasif voilà
c'est un des arguments c'est de dire ses
17 euros alors d'humaniser pas assez en
tout cas visiblement à paris donc
donc oui bah
vivre les gens iront l'heure mais on
part en ayant aussi c'est cohérent avec
le principe de la décentralisation sa
réclament la responsabilité il ya un
grand problème avec les finances locales
on sait jamais qui est responsable de
quoi
et à quoi sont imputables à qui a
qu'elle et lui est imputable une hausse
d'impôts locaux c'est très compliqué de
décrypter les feuilles commencent
bon là on saura au moins acquis sans
procès le maire allait voir monsieur le
maire moi j'ai découvert mon britannique
mais c'est ça remonte il ya dix ans
c'est vous dire
à l'époque quand vous dépassez de cinq
minutes le stationnement autorisé à
londres où anthony lanoë la prune
c'était 65 livres c'est qu'à l'époque
c'était 100 euros c'était il ya dix ans
je peux vous dire que vous le faites une
fois deux fois puis s'est terminée après
vous dépassez palissy à 2h pression'
mans vous revenez à deux heures pile
vous êtes revenu un sélecteur c'est une
règle rigide une pratique molle c'est un
fait voilà ça change quoi le pari et ils
nous ont battus par est un peu l'inversé
d'autres personnes et il préside le seul
problème juste pour finir parce que des
idiomes eos et que on aimerait bien moi
aussi je l'état peut être libres
d'utiliser effectivement d'un match
comme il veut sauf que quand on voit
l'état 55 % du pib des dépenses
publiques
on aimerait avoir une léger regard un
peu plus acéré sur les dépenses de
l'état
alors ils seront sur les routes
également cet été
les coureurs du tour de france le sexe
le sujet vous aspirent tous beaucoup on
a découvert cet après midi le nouveau
tracé
il partira le tour de france partira de
l'île de noirmoutier offre un grand tour
on le voit là l'écran lé un grand tour
en bretagne pour monter vers le nord et
vers roubaix
et puis ensuite la partie des cols des
pyrénées des alpes et
changement enfin disons nouveauté c'est
le plateau des glières cette année avec
évidemment l'hommage à la résistance
mais cette particularité que ça se
terminera sur un chemin et non plus sur
route à deux kilomètres de voies de
chemin les force à lille force a dérobé
alors mais non mais ya le retour des
pavés il ressort des pavés du mottay
damian cela en fait un lien avec 25 km
de pareils ça c'est toujours très
spectaculaire pour les amateurs bon et
on vous allez voir refleurir à la suite
son plein gré et les hôpitaux il est
et les voilà mais on attend un peu là on
est encore dans le découverte du tracé
le dopage ce sera pour plus tard
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi ne restez sur
figaro life vous allez découvrir un
focus présenté par ariane le coeur avec
tristan v qui va tout vous expliquer sur
cette découverte scientifique majeure
sur les ondes gravitationnelles
c'est une révolution pour
l'astrophysique
merci à bientôt
[Musique]